hi Chris hi dad I don't know what my
waist thin is but it's probably not
right what is the importance of wingspan
now I don't think it's all that
important it's in the month of May it's
a huge talking point because there's not
a lot going on in that month to wrap
related the combine comes up and if you
have a guy over 610 who has a wingspan
shorter than his height it's all he's
asked about I remember a couple years
back I mean the biggest knock on cody
zeller coming out of indiana with that
he he might have had a shorter wingspan
than people expected then people were
losing their minds about it but
ultimately when when you get to draft
night I mean that's way down on the list
of things people care about as far as
the draft itself it feels like it's all
going to fall into place you might have
something with Tatum Fox or Josh Jackson
but is there a deal or deals that you
think will impact tonight's draft well
there's a couple of things that that I'm
keeping my eye on number one is what
happens with Paul George I think it
there's a very good chance that
something happens significant with
George either to the Lakers or somebody
else prior to the start of the draft
imitate the Pacers want to be in
distress and if they're going to deal
Paul George they want to get guys that
you know that they can draft now and
start the rebuilding process before now
they're not going to get number two from
the Lakers but they might get a couple
of picks and there could be no seem to
swoop in the 11th hour and make that
deal the other team I'm looking at at
least you want to hear is Boston and I
think there's still a possibility Boston
could trade down here I think they liked
Jason Tatum a lot at number 3 and if
they stay there I think that's going to
be the guy but there's a lot of teams
you know inquiring to Boston right now
both with some offers for veteran
players and draft takes to move back
down the draft so I I don't know that
Bob's done feeling quite yet the next
situation with porzingis is somebody
willing to pony up enough for them to
move him I mean
that that interview that Phil Jackson
did I mean a in house interview I've
given up
really understanding what goes through
Phil Jackson says I really do I I don't
know I don't know why he would just be
so emotional about an exit interview
that but people looked up later other
players have done it before Shaq did to
him back in 2003 it just doesn't make a
lot of sense now I don't think a deal
gets done before Zynga because there are
a lot of people in the organization that
you know unless it's a godfather feel
they will stand up and just Intel still
absolutely guy you cannot do this this
guy's is too good and too young but you
know as you could tell from last night
and what I've been hearing for for all
week yo Phil is is very serious about
this I mean if there's an offer that
makes sense
you know he'll make a deal now words
reported last night into this morning
that that Phoenix was team that that
that the Knicks were looking at but that
the Knicks aren't going to get Devin
Booker out of Phoenix and if they can't
there's there's no trade there to be had
so I think porzingis stays but you have
to wonder at this point then have they
done irreparable damage to this
relationship two years in and they've
really alienated this kid and I wonder
just how their watch is how and what
they're going to do to fix it Jimmy
Butler's situation is what he could move
you know Chicago is less likely I think
than Indiana to make a move with Butler
on draft day I think the Bulls I think
they feel like they could go into the
offseason see kind of where the dominoes
fall where how the dust settles with
teams like Boston and others when it
comes to free agency you know Boston
wants Gordon a word I mean that's
they're not going to make a deal I don't
think that that gobbles into their cap
space because they want to make a run at
Hayward they think they can get them so
like the Brompton won't make I don't
think would make a brother type of deal
before they can go out and make their
pitch to Heyward but if they don't get
him I think it's possible
down the line into July that they
explore explore deal with the bulls so
they're talking about Jimmy bother the
teams but
I don't know that necessarily happens on
Drago Chris Mannix yahoo sports the
vertical they have their special tonight
starting at 6:30 Eastern NBA draft live
coverage the Lakers game plan now is
what well it's clear cap space and that
you saw with the deal that that moved
Russell and Mozgov off the books mean
Brook Lopez is not in their long-term
plans they want the cap space that Lopez
creates I mean the biggest question they
face now is did they go into their their
assets and deal for Paul George now or
do they roll the dice and hope that
George doesn't get traded to a Boston or
a Portland or a team that he might like
to play for and decide that he wants to
stay but they're their entire their
entire strategy bin seems to be based on
the summer of 2018 when there could be
some massive free agents that are out
there free ages with ties to the Los
Angeles area
Russell Westbrook Paul Georgian and
absolutely LeBron James I mean there
they're going to be first in line to
make their pitch to LeBron in 2018 and
if they can get a commit for Paul George
before then if Lonzo ball this season
looks like a franchise point guard
there's some optimism in LA that they
can make something work but could you
see a scenario where Chris Paul stays
with the Clippers where Melo ends up
with the Clippers and LeBron ends up
with the Clippers possibly um you know
LeBron is going to look at situations
that that he thinks he can win in I mean
that's going to be you know it's got to
be a top priority and I wonder if you
know Braun was looking at his career
he's not looking as a one-off he's not
going to look go to the Clippers for one
year and then then explore you know the
Lakers the next I wonder if he looks at
the Clippers a year from now with
Carmelo a year older with Chris Paul at
33 himself would be 30 almost 34 does he
think that team in one season can
challenge Golden State in the Western
Conference I don't really see it if the
Lakers at least if you got Paul George
and you've got Chris Paul there are you
got that sponsor ball there you can have
something for through a three-year type
of run and maybe you could cobble
together some pieces around them that
could put you in a title position plus I
really think Dan you you have to wonder
about Chris Paul
and if he's going to be there because
San Antonio if what they did with that
that Pau Gasol deal I mean it's vicious
first it's like a nice most popular deal
getting call Gasol to tops out of his
contract but it might be the most
important if they can move one more
piece and it maybe it's Danny Green
maybe it's Tony Parker though I have a
hard time seeing them cut ties with
Parker at this point if they can move
one more piece they can have that max
level money and I think they'll they'll
make a run at Chris Paul or Kyle Lowry
to summer the least risky pick tonight
is who uh uh I mean I've been a long
believer in folks but if you want to go
a little bit down I think Tatum is the
least risky pick because I think he's
he's going to be an NBA scorer and I
think he's going to be able to score two
positions he's going to come in as a
three man but as his body fills out a
little bit I think he's going to make a
really good you know 2017 version NBA
for guy that's why I think Boston likes
him because I think you can play Tatum
and Jalen Brown together it's not warm
the other which it might be with Josh
Jackson but I think that Tatum is going
to be able to come in and play right
away the riskiest pick so see my issue
is you're recording all this yesterday
and I'm really I'm going to eat this uh
like I think Darren Fox at least in that
that top five six seven range is risky I
look at him and I've heard two things in
terms of the red flag department number
one he's a real real skinny kid like you
see his body is not playing the point
guard in the NBA it's grueling and and
people have looked at him and said I
don't know how big he gets how how much
he fills out and more importantly the
shots not fair he's not 25% from three
during college hey can he get good
enough to make you know 35 36 percent as
a pro you you just don't survive I mean
they're they're few and far between the
guy that survived that position who
can't shoot Rondo was one of them you
seeing elfrid Payton in Orlando who is
really struggling and not his other
talents aren't being showcased because
he can't shoot the basketball
I think Fox Fox is a big risk to me
because of those two factors
seaton where we recording that of course
okay yeah we got that Mannix all right
have fun tonight any kind of eat peas
like probably like six months from now
to be eating there we'd have it no other
way
we never bring back anything that you
said it was right yeah see why wait six
months yeah I'm sure it'll be here we
might do it tomorrow
karma League yeah yes thank you Chris
all right then that's Chris Mannix the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience